my name is Matt welcome back to Anna
let's just get this best started in hey
that's a Kestrel right this will
probably be the last episode mr.
chairman
we're up in the attic man let's go
mannequin Jeremy hi everyone it's good
to be back it's good to be back have no
[ __ ] clue what to do this time around
I have not cheated maybe I don't need a
cheat I have a very good intuition I
think what
[Music]
oh it's Greer you know what
oh he bought me a present it's a
deformed trans
it's shut up shut up baby what do you
want
how about his mask did I get mask no way
what about this nice pickup I'll take
them all
baby you ain't got you frown
[Music]
yes I can't use them
why does it say you are gay learning
from a pile of leaves a problem at once
touch something so green light shut up
baby over here have a black dress I'm
exhausted well it makes sense in real
life the baby cries you give it give it
some plant for me I make no sense either
shut up game you give it an iron bar
that makes no sense a that you give the
baby some ashes about burning heart your
are so picky
piece of [ __ ] child so oh I know I know
I know
let's make a beautiful thing here let's
combine these two the vest has emerged
with masks as if it
oh look at that this is my outfit right
there I got it we're gonna put you down
on this little clothing thing you would
think you put it on a mannequin but no
Jeremy this is my true form baby what
the hell is going on here I don't know
but I'm looking at your penis but your
zipper is open baby and I can what stop
don't look at it I can't help opinion
I'm looking at your fly's open
it's close it stop stop stop looking at
me that's funny man not cool what do you
want stop cry will you stop crying yeah
[Music]
that [ __ ] right in my tutor I don't
know where my children what what do you
want I have a face of truth you're not
gonna go to college you're gonna end up
like a [ __ ] and be pregnant how I died
that's your trouble
are you still crying maybe cuz you're a
crybaby that's why it happened you're
gonna yeah [ __ ] why did you do that
hey guys got flipper
stop looking at me buddy but buddy what
girl look at that body girl I can what
take the leaves what I might
you suckle your mama pudding so anything
else we got to do I'm a chef
also I gotta tell you I've ever but what
the hell I'd really be heading this is
burning so feminine and the route seems
resistance to the heart of fire
all right good route glad you're
resistant to the hotter fire
I'm about to get ya while I fell back to
life it from the house I don't have a
clear idea what happened to my leaf all
right well don't let's not leave son of
a [ __ ] upstairs Jeremy took my life
Jeremy
at a mechanic
why would you just throw like a mother
that's going on here very very very
quickly indeed yes yes yes it's got to
be something buddy's flame down by your
flaming boy I did wonder hi what are you
doing what are you Joe stop I'm not
gonna high-five you so many time I'm
gonna hop I feel like peony I'm not
gonna do it that's gonna have five any
shut up game
what if I told you nothing I told you I
will not shut up the tree of hands and
stuff back me Thalia I'm not gonna have
a birth you know I'm closing this door
now okay I told you I'm closing the door
now that's right
shut up door what are you looking at me
now think it's funny
you thought that was funny I didn't it
[ __ ] flame why don't you just burn
like the rest while you do extra bags
what do you want an iron pipe No so
greedy just like the baby upstairs I
took my leave to the new yeah fine well
I'm going up then I gotta pick up more
[Music]
that ladder you
I'm looking at your penis beating stop
looking at me
what is your deal what is your deal bro
stop product I'm not gonna make out with
you is that what you want cuz I'm not
gonna do it have a girlfriend I'm not
making out with Matt I was a baby come
here what do you want
I haven't even eats now because you
freaking took them back you little [ __ ]
don't think I don't know that you don't
and I'm in real I mean alright God I'm
not gonna cheat or anything it's just I
got a I got AI got aa
alright we are back you're still looking
at my penis are you there's a couple
things that needs to be done
and I don't like the fact that I have to
stop lumina I hate it shut up living in
Italy seriously they have problem in
this sewer smell like it's not me all
right
there's a [ __ ] bowl here and see that
[ __ ] up I have a more than best that's
pretty cool I know why you wouldn't
notice shut up
I'm sorry let's go up again girl and
he's gonna start with me
right I'm Patti you came back
[Music]
was whispering whispering is not allowed
in this room are you whispering
it's got the baby where's the baby
how do I stop crying court you did it
well you know what I do to crying babies
you know what I doubt I stab you in a
sacrificial dagger what that is dead nut
are you throwing a period on me now
nosebleed I come on stop that yet ah
well there's only one thing you can do
when the child has knows you take it in
a bowl and that makes it stop
[Music]
yes now what else it's clothing over
here I want to check it out
let's go it's in light candle bad music
gee I never had this to me fine I don't
know what I feel about it
alright let's give you give you plant
why not
I don't like platform day
I don't want to give it to the chair
that's what I need to do with this I
gotta use sorry I don't know why did hey
do you make me angry you touch my
nipples I'm sorry man I'm really sorry
supposed to eliminate oh there you guys
that's awesome
and now let's peel some nose baby blood
on you stop what are you doing over that
baby shut up you stand your business my
Swedish mother once upon a time I cook
today I shall aid prize
and I think you did something to shut up
I know what I'm doing okay I don't know
what a minute
twice shaking
whoa why did he do that I went to
management
I saw you don't [ __ ] me
I know you
and I just give
up to me where to go
I guess I clean your pity
I can see myself there enough
but today though but I didn't do
anything I wanted to play it's like this
I'm outta here
later [ __ ] and regedit all right what
the hell why I'm sure it's fine what I
made it yay
how strange in the forest night it's
telling me maybe I feel so bad because I
want to discover such a girl killed in
that way
I have no idea what the hell is going on
maybe she was the same girl I met in
nowit's baby the day I injuries full of
grace and gentleness and I walk her way
back when I think I was engaged Almighty
can't even remember her I was so drying
colletion it's hard to not think about
it see red flakes you see there it's
usually the color of flames and the way
new ways to think I'm creepy
yes I hear that was something fearsome
it's nights I don't like that
I was naming me I died tonight
I'm hurt corrupted in body and mind son
of a [ __ ] I guess we got a meeting and
we finish this first ending it's
actually not the first ending but I
don't really feel like playing anymore
right now it would be too long of an
episode anyway but if you wanted me to
play the other endings maybe maybe it
all depends on what kind of ratings and
views this video again because I don't
really feel like it so it's it's up to
you breasts but anyway like if you
enjoyed it subscribe for every not seen
except for what everyone may know I'm
backin up backin up backin up backin up
cause my daddy taught me good
[Music]